my guest tonight is an award-winning
actor who's been seen in the divergent
series and big little lies for latest
film endings beginnings is now available
digitally on all platforms and video on
demand please welcome the incredibly
talented shailene woodley hey thank you
so much for joining me and for doing
this I really appreciate it it's
actually because I'm in my house and
nope trust me nobody here wants to talk
to me this nice treat that I have that
I'm able to say oh I like Shailene I get
to go talk to her for for 15 minutes and
I get to run upstairs and just do that
so I feel like this is saving my life
and then you know it's it's it's sort of
like a side benefit of this weird gig
that I have so thankfully well thank you
for continuing to do it I mean you could
have easily chosen not to so thank you
for well maybe you didn't have a choice
maybe like it would be good to keep
going and keep everybody working and
doing it but I have to tell you there
have been times where I'm attempting to
put on my own makeup a lot of makeup for
you today and did my hair you look
really great I'm gonna be honest with
you I don't have anything you look you
look great I'm I'm 95 years old and my
team looks great it's just it's the
cheapest ring light in the world I just
know you have a ring lay your chicken
man I have that it's it's that's it I'd
window light no you look great you look
great it's just that I think 95% of my
look is this and then I'm gonna start
hanging wax paper over this to give you
that nice blurred filters yeah I want to
look like a very attractive late 1920s
film star there you go Arlette I've been
doing this a really long time and for
the first time everybody I'm talking to
is in the exact same situation do you
not I mean we're all in quarantine
so I always start off asking people
how's your quarantine going quarantine
is actually going good I mean it's you
know it's weird because it's hard to say
I'm having a great time because you know
that like the reason we're in quarantine
is cuz so many other people aren't
having a great time right now um but for
me it's it's been nice to be home
I never home so the opportunity to just
understand what domestic life can be and
get to know your neighbors and you know
six feet apart
of course um it's been it's been really
lovely I guess to have this to have this
time how about you it's pretty good I
think what the biggest difference
between say what you're going from what
I'm going through is I'm in this house
with my wife and my two kids and a bunch
of animals you are just with your dog is
that right I'm just my dog that is a
major different anyone who has children
who's going through this I have a friend
who has three to three kids and a that's
just so many kids to begin with but B
being stuck with all three of those
children oh yeah yeah gotcha yeah I I
have to say it really depends on their
ages like my children are young teens
but that means they're completely
self-sufficient
Juden I mean like they they're just
doing their own thing but for dinner and
that's it exactly and they want to see
me as little as possible I'm an
embarrassment to them so they just don't
want me around but I was thinking if I
were you and I was holed up just with my
dog I would start to lose it I would
start to think the dog was talking to me
well he's talking to me
I mean that he's thought he's actually
singing to me as well he's serenading me
dog you know he's gonna have such a rude
awakening when when the world starts up
again when he realizes he doesn't get my
attention 24 hours a day like he does
right now right for him the great thing
about dogs I think is they immediately
forget most everything really hard for
me I hope I do that with this quarantine
I wish I could be like a dog and when
this is over just be like okay that
didn't happen
on to the notes yeah you're donating
some of your time for a good cause it's
actually a cause is this right that your
mom started called
all it takes is that right it is we
started it together ten years ago and
then I was just like mom I don't have
the bandwidth to really funnel all of my
energy into this so she took it over and
she's doing amazing work I mean right
now specifically they've created a
program because there's so many people
at home dealing with anxiety and it's
kind of this weird thing that we're not
talking about a lot I feel like when it
comes to Kovac but people are at home
they don't know when they're gonna work
again kids have parents teaching them
homework that parents don't you know
they don't know what they're doing and
suicide rates are up and depression is
up and people just don't have tools to
cope and so there's a program online
that she's created every Sunday and then
multiple times throughout the month they
go on and have these panels and
discussions on how you can cope with the
anxiety that you're experiencing at home
what up no matter what age you're at I
think that's a really good point because
my experience has been people think if
you're just staying in your home you
almost don't have the right to be
anxious and there's a lot of people
saying they do that well there's real
people out there on the frontlines and
the hospital worker is they deserve to
be anxious but not me because I'm at
home eating a burrito and binge watching
you know some TV show when the point is
there's a lot of anxiety out there oh
imagine how many people I don't know if
they're ever gonna work again who have
been laid off because they weren't in
the top one-third of their company's
employees and there's so much
uncertainty and I think are in our
country too we we don't really have we
didn't have any way to prepare for this
so yeah resources for anxiety are major
and may is the Mental Health Awareness
Month so yeah it is true well on a
happier note I know that you're a big
star Wars fan I'm such a big star Wars
fan and not
and you know it's funny because now our
life before quarantine we look back on
it and it feels like a hundred years ago
you know but I know that just before the
quarantine wanted of like in January you
know pretty not that long ago you went
to what's it called galaxy's edge the
Star Wars experience at Disneyland I
went it was our new years my best
friends and I heard like New Year
celebration we went to Disneyland and
went to galaxy's edge and it I mean
listen I as a child in kindergarten
refused to go about my name and people
had to call me Leia and I found the two
boys in the class that I was friends
with a cute one I made Han Solo and the
one that I didn't think was that cute
was Luke and could be my brother and we
just played Star Wars every single day
it was a part of my DNA
um so being that as an adult and
witnessing what they created at
Disneyland I mean this is this is fully
an unpaid advertisement you have to go
to Disneyland to witness galaxy's edge
if you like Star Wars you're promoting
Disneyland and galaxy's edge and you're
not getting paid to do it because for a
minute I thought okay usually when
someone's yelling at me go to Disneyland
it's because they're getting paid a
couple hundred thousand dollars but yeah
that's great but we have you posted some
footage of you at galaxy's edge I think
getting interrogated by a stormtrooper
we have something in common because when
I grew up I had everyone called me Leia
as well really put the buns on your head
too yeah yeah that was very gender
confused but I for me she was the one I
could relate to the most
and I'm curious I mean now you're in
this position as a Star Wars fan where
they're these the Star Wars universe
will never end they keep making new new
projects and new characters do you ever
think to yourself wait a minute I might
be able to be in one of those and if so
what would you be what what kind of
character would you want to be I mean I
would love it's probably sounds crazy if
the opportunity to be a lead in the Star
Wars film came around
listen I wouldn't say no but I also just
think it'd be really cool to be an extra
I think it'd be very cool to put on like
a stormtrooper uniform and show up to
set all day and sit there for 12 hours
doing the same walk back and forth and
just witnessing the magic because there
is there's something so magical about
movies like that and part of you know
being an actor is you see the inside of
it and sometimes that's great and other
times it can take some the magic away so
I don't know that I'd want to ruin the
magic for myself but that yeah you
having youth you're this big star you
have a lot of clout you love Star Wars
and if you could be any character you'd
want to be an extra running in the
background with a helmet on yes yeah do
you remember the movie hook how many
people like we're extras in that movie
just popped up who are friends like I
love that I think that's so cool and I
don't know I would I just I think if you
need just tell my kids one day see that
see that soldier that's me that was me
they'll never believe me but but you
could also show them movies where you
hear this star I mean this is true
you're not wrong but I just I don't know
it's great it's sweet I just find it
really funny that you let's talk about
endings beginnings there's a lot of
improvisation in this film which I would
imagine takes a lot of I would
say courage as an actor to do that much
improvisation because then the director
can if you're if you're improvising a
scene for 20 minutes and the director
can cut it down to two they have a lot
of control over what happens yeah you're
completely right I mean the good thing
is that our director Drake doremus most
of his films that he's improvised not
most uh he hasn't improvised all of his
films in the films that he has
improvised are incredible and I'm a huge
fan of and he's just somebody who really
cares about people and about emotions
and my humanity in love and suffering
and pain and and I think that you know
being in one of his movies you kind of
know what you sign up for you're
completely right and we will do scenes
for 20 minutes and then he'd come up to
us and say hey I really liked this
sentence and I like this sentence how do
we now put these two sentences and make
a new scene out of them and so the whole
thing like one big improvised impro
improvisational still not say that word
experiment and we really got to know
ourselves very well because when you are
improvising you're pulling from your own
well of knowledge and experience and I
think you surprised yourself with some
of the things you say sometimes Wow I
would prefer a script yeah I think
different director a script would be
nice though with this no it felt great I
know I mean it's it's really cool that
you did that I just think and I'm not an
actor but I would think to be an actor
and have to excavate your own feelings
and probably mine your past and try and
feel things and expose parts of yourself
I'd be like can I have a script yeah I
mean it was really vulnerable super
vulnerable I feel like I got to know
those actors and our crew as well
because they were improvising the whole
time in many ways more than I've ever
gotten to know any other actor or crew
on any film set Wow okay so this I want
to make sure I get this out there
because this is endings beginnings is
now available digitally on all platforms
and video on-demand I like to call that
far
not anybody else calls it violet I'm the
only person alright well I worry about
you because you're alone in a house with
a dog for a very long time I will come
out of this okay I'm people enjoy this
because they're kind of shy so they love
it I love it I mean I can do the whole
extrovert thing if I have to but I'm
such an introvert and there's like a
cozy cocoon so I'm very happy all right
hey thank you so much Bailey take care
of yourself
I will you - and I will see you on the
other side of this craziness yes you
give my best to the dog I will give my
best your family